what is the temperament you think right
now when it comes to just the city of
memphis it always feels like i mean you
guys like i said when it comes to hip
hop
memphis is on fire for sure but it also
feels like a very divided place in
certain aspects there's you know there's
some artists who are kind of like you
know kind of neutral it seems like but
for the most part it seems like a real
divided place like how is the
temperament in the city right now
there's a lot of pride and a lot of
people feeling like
one person's success
like
is gonna make them not successful like
right like your success don't got [ __ ]
to do with mine exactly like billions of
people in the world pocket watching you
know what i'm saying that pocket
watching to get you man when you start
looking at across the aisle what someone
else is doing
and you let that make you feel a certain
type of way about what you're doing yeah
that's where you start [ __ ] up and
they'll be hating and loving you at the
same time
that's real yeah so this me if it's just
you know they just
they'll they'll start off as fans you
know what i'm saying and
like what you're doing but once they get
to the point to where they'll be using
this motivation but once they get to the
point they feel like they want to be
better than you they think they got to
step on you to be building when it's
like no you just do your thing stay
motivated you ain't gotta be better than
the next person to be a good you a
hundred percent
like you said be yourself that's some
real [ __ ]